Happening at Johns Hopkins Hospital with the Psilocybin experimenters because
one of the most recent things they showed was that if you take people dying of
cancer and you'd give them cell assignment and they have a mystical experience,
which is something like an experience of the Kingdom of God on earth,
but also eternally at the same time that they lose their fear of death or did
it,
at least it's much modified it,
you know,
that's a hell of a finding.
That's really,
you can't just,
you can't just walk away from that easily because that's a hell of a thing to
treat.
Well,
yeah,
I have a chapter on that then in heavens on earth,
on near death experiences.
Um,
it's so,
but we're talking about two different things.
Um,
you know,
the transitioning from life to death in the most pain free or anxiety reduced
state is,
is more,
is progress.
Uh,
you know,
medical progress,
psychological progress or whatever and I'm all for,
you know,
is psilocybin does it or whatever.
Um,
then great,
we should do that.
But there's a lot of people that claim more than that,
that this is opening the doors of perception into another world.
It's actually out there and that those of us had not taken acid.
We just simply can't know.
So now we,
now we get at this question of truth.
You know,
one of my columns and scientific American and I recently wrote called,
what is truth anyway?
I mean,
when I say like I prefer dark,
dark chocolate and you prefer milk chocolate,
you know,
there's no truth that is to be discovered.
Years is true for you.
Mine's Poop for me.
Or I say stairway to heaven as the greatest rock song of all time.
And you say,
no,
Freebird is better than stairway to heaven.
And we argue about that,
but there's no,
there's no experiment we're going to run.
And so as we start to move along these lines,
like when Deepak Chopra tells me meditation works,
okay,
so if it works for you or it doesn't work for me,
those are still in that state of internal truths.
But what we want to know in science,
it doesn't work for everybody.
Or,
you know,
67% of people that do an hour of meditation a day under these conditions have
reduced stress hormones and blood pressure.
And so in some measurable way that's different than just an internal state.
So when we're talking about,
again just to,
you know,
working on,
towards,
towards striving to better ourselves or,
or some kind of heaven,
if you mean just,
you know,
metaphorically so that I can better myself,
that's different than there was an actual place you can go to a,
that's going to be there after we die.
And so I think this is where scientists go.
You also started messing about with the idea of place in a way that that's the
problem with having discussions about fundamental realities.
And you know,
when you said another thing that Christ said was that the Kingdom of Heaven is
spread upon earth,
but men do not see it.
Right?
So,
and,
and that's,
that's something that's akin to the idea of that Kingdom of God is within you.
Although it's,
it's a strange twist on it because it also adds an element of externalities or
physicality to it.
And an element of immediacy,
not something that's forestalled into the future.
But I wonder,
see,
in my wilder moments of speculation,
I have this notion that if things stack up properly,
so imagine that you're immersed in a very deeply meaningful experience and,
and it's,
it's operating.
It's indicating that harmony has been established between multiple levels of
being simultaneously.
I wonder if that can,
I wonder if that can put you in a place that's profound enough or deep enough so
that the structure of time and space itself starts to warp around that.
I mean,
I know that that's a,
I can't formulate it well,
but there's,
there's something,
there's something about it that seems to me to be correct about that,
because people have intimations of a murder of a mortality,
and they have intimations of,
of,
of heavenly and hellish a boats as well.
And they're not,
they're not,
they're not the simple kind of rational,
even rational,
fundamentalist beliefs that often people talk about when they're discussing
religious belief.
They're more reflected in direct experience and it's not easy to make sense of
them.